was mich einige am meisten beschäftigt
gerade ist die frage und glaube ich die
auch viele zuschauer interessiert und
vielleicht kann uns andere manager
weiterhelfen was hat jetzt dieser
schulter besuch eigentlich bei punkten
gebracht oder nicht gebracht und was
wissen sie darüber und inwieweit steht
die ukrainische regierung jetzt mit
schröder in kontakt weil politiker hatte
ja gemeldet dass dieser besuch zurück
geht auf einen ukrainischen abgeordneten
unter schröder auch am rande einer
ukrainischen delegation in istanbul
gewesen sei und dann von dort nach
moskau zu fliegen und es schien
sozusagen die mission zu sein putin
davon zu überzeugen dass er direkt mit
selensky verhandelt was wissen sie
darüber liegt
ja das ist
ein spannendes thema muss man sagen und
wurde sehr gezielt gesetzt
und das freut mich dass schröder
jetzt bild tv zuschauer ist wo er dann
das verfolgt was was hier besprochen
werden geraten und
das war eben ein ganz spontaner gedanken
eigentlich ein 1 1 ein kreativer
vorschlag wieso sollten wir herrn
schröder jetzt abschreiben auch wenn
wenn wie gesagt wenn ich persönlich
nicht viel respekt für diese man habe
aber trotzdem vielleicht hat er noch
eine letzte mittel haben ein sehr es
ihrem ruf gefolgt ich kann mir das auch
gut vorstellen so viel nach acht wird
von vielen politikern geschaut der
mensch aber dass da sage noch mal ja das
wissen wir nicht aber aber was was heute
noch mal ganz konkret ganz konkret
das muss man ja mittlerweile wissen also
politik und berichtet diese abgeordnete
sei mehr oder weniger auf auftrag von
oder in kontakt zumindest auch mit dem
präsidenten gewesen dafür habe ich
bislang weiterhin keine bestätigung aus
ukrainischen quält ich weiß nicht wie es
ihnen geht ob sie damit ich darf in
mainz noch keine einzelheiten verraten
aber so weit gar nicht schon sagen
dieser vorschlag oder dieser idee kam
von herrn schröder in den letzten tagen
das war keine bitte oder
von von der ukrainische seite sondern
das war eben schröder hat sich gemeldet
nicht direkt indirekt aber immerhin und
und vielen direkt gemeldet er hat über
über
gewisse kontakte die auch kontakte zur
ukraine haben und es wurde signalisiert
nachhilfe dass er bereit wäre mal zu
versuchen und das heißt das kann ich
heute bestätigen das heißt das war nicht
eine initiative aus kiel sondern
umgekehrt und das heißt das dass herr
schröder vielleicht tatsächlich noch
versuchte auch seinen sein ansehen ein
bisschen aufzupolieren und doch einen
anderen platz in der geschichte für sich
zu entdecken dabei bleiben wir werden
übrigens darauf direkt jetzt
zurückkommen ich muss ihn aber in
rechnung abgeben ich muss aber wir
bleiben bei diesem thema also direkt
nach der kleinen werbeunterbrechung sind
wir zurück und wir werden weiter darüber
sprechen mit hermann echtes gleich
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauer wir haben gerade mit hennig
heißt darüber debattiert und wir waren
eigentlich schon fast dabei ist
herauszufinden sind bleiben will es auch
bei dem thema wenig über wessen kontakte
wie kann das treffen mit herr schröder
zustande sie sind ja ein mann der
offenen worte
ja also ich kann nur soweit sorgen dass
das über linie verlag lief das ganze das
heißt gewisse berichte kann ich auch
bestätigen aber vor allem geht es darum
dass diese initiative von herrn schröder
kam
auch wenn auch wenn wie gesagt auch wenn
man dann nicht viel hoffnung gibt aber
das was wir auch in diesem studio wir
besprochen haben erst vor einer woche
das gilt nämlich es gibt nicht so viele
menschen weltweit und auch in
deutschland vielleicht die diesen
persönlichen draht so händchen haben und
deswegen hat auch vielleicht erst einmal
das gespürt ja vielleicht hat er diese
kraft mal vielleicht traut er sich mal
nach moskau zu pflegen und wir allen
bereits herbei ja
ja ja wenn ich das ja ganz wichtiger
punkt weil bislang
ist ja sozusagen muss man vielleicht
einmal zusammenfassend für die zuschauer
die lage die nachrichtliche lage so dass
bislang die menschen davon ausgegangen
sind so scheint es zumindest schröder
dargestellt zu haben wir wissen nicht
was die quelle von politik ist das
ukraine auf ihn zugegangen sind sie
sagen jetzt das war genau anders herum
und es ist ja schon ein sehr wichtiger
hintergrund wo man jetzt auch die frage
stellen muss welche motivation hatte er
schröder offenbar angespornt durch sie
herr botschafter nämlich sie haben genau
das bei viertel nach acht vor ungefähr
zehn tagen gesagt dass sie das gut
finden wenn das passiert dennoch wenn
die initiative von schröder jetzt
ausging was glauben sie ist oder war
seine motivation das zu tun geht es
darum so zu sagen klar zu machen und zu
versuchen sein image wiederherzustellen
oder glauben sie dass er tatsächlich ein
ehrliches interesse bzw
das gefühl hat dass er bei putin etwas
verändern kann weil wir müssen ja mal
sagen stand jetzt hat er nichts
verändert also wladimir putin hat
angekündigt nach dem treffen wir fast
einmal kurz zusammen das 16 1000 kämpfer
von assad in die ukraine kommen könnten
er hat möglicherweise soldaten von
lukaschenko angeworben die kommen sollen
oder lukas schinko tritt im krieg ein
und die kriege der krieg geht hier
weiter also da ist auch mal nicht
erreicht worden oder
also mal sehen also ich kann insoweit
sagen dass eventuell morgen wir auch
direkt von den schweden hören werden
also was was waren die ergebnisse dieser
dieses treffen sie mit herrn putin und
was die motivation betrifft das was bau
jetzt eine fragte ich glaube das war
beides ja sowohl das image vielleicht
ein bisschen aufzupolieren als auch
vielleicht doch ein beitrag zu leisten
dass dieser krieg zu ende geht mal sehen
inwieweit er erfolgreich war bei seinen
kumpel putin aber zumindest das ist ein
pflanzen wissen es doch schon oder ich
habe das gefühl sie wissen dass schröder
morgen etwas sagen wird in welche
richtung es gehen wird wissen sie also
das ist weiß nicht wo und also ehrlich
gesagt also ich weiß dass herr schröder
bereit ist darüber zu berichten über
kanäle die jetzt weiß ich nicht
öffentliche laufen und das ist gut dass
das man zumindest fragen muss man bei
bild live auftreten will